welcome to this video playing on Anene
an awning from Spain and I'm going to
announce right away that I'm going to
win this game yep I will I have lost the
last three and I really need a win here
I was so comfortably above 2,400 those
three losses they really hurt so I will
do everything to win am I mean within
within my abilities and within fair play
let's see got some sort of Oh sloth
gloom fault type of type of position g6
is not very very common and here it
started with the sloth but then you've
just played g6 okay okay I don't want a
double porn at this moment yeah there is
95 not really doing much ok that's just
let's just complete development here 94
can be an idea the double pawn ok
interesting
I don't really think that it helps him
that much the night only for it's also a
liability for night h4 yeah and here
this is interesting because i have night
a5 that's a very important point Knight
a5 attacks be Sun and it's very tough to
play against ok so that's an interesting
try what is his point if I go in and say
Bishop f4 ok this looks good anyway and
I want to play a bit quicker here as
mentioned I'm going to win the game and
i'm not i'm not going to lose on time
here so i'll play quickly night be five
maybe it could be complete good now so
if i go here and then bishop c2 not good
ok so should I just ignore this thread
III is III mmm my why not why not
actually 9 a-5 is still in the position
and III ng3 is sometimes the weird
combination because of the bishop on f4
which has no natural retweet square but
it's it's it's not really a we are going
to be attacked soon
good moves are Luke fc1 and Knight a5
those those are gaudium as possible ways
to strengthen the position yeah this is
this is also interesting I was thinking
about this but I thought this is just
good a thought yeah let's do that and
then Brooksie one next
yeah almost 1 minute head on the clock
not bad look see one night a fiver this
is this is very annoying okay let's just
play a quick move here to prevent g5
yeah okay so this one with the temple
and I am this and now I thought 95 is he
going e5 but that's not that much on a
problem if I can really just take and
take night eggs and I don't see a
concrete threat the night is active only
five but I'm still just taking be 700
Ford's apart ok I take here take here
take 1d6 neck let's just take everything
here c6 is also hanging ya know let me
think for a moment but I think this is
just good right just take here and
detect the rook or is there better not
so when he's playing with chicken with
this idea to capture and be too but ok
I'm going to take here first this must
be right ok so if I just recapture yeah
I should recapture really ok there
should be two I just retreat the bishop
and I'm a p sub i thought or not maybe
bishop a fire with a temp oh yeah I'm a
piece up really can't in one of the rook
seven captioned this is still just a
piece
yeah and I've got Ruger c7 coming yeah
rook rook c7 yeah nothing nothing
special yeah what now yeah okay come on
just to exchange this so just going for
a technical win
totally sure why he wants to continue
but ok because it's really easy check
check check yeah of course it'sit's
nights so you can think about I mean
maybe yeah if you get to eliminate
everything here but it's not going going
to happen I hear 95 yards I should
really avoid check black resigns yeah
let's let's look a little bit back here
yeah this is a fairly normal position
but okay I think you should really i'm
not sure if you should take really very
often black should play something like
that against there this night see for
ideas simply because the position here
is problematic this Knight a5 idea is
always very annoying especially in
combination with the bishop coming to f4
so that moon flag would be eight at some
point it's not easy easily playable can
be M can be tricky here for black it's
it could have played Knight b6 yes this
would have been easier here I'm better
but 96 wins the exchange okay okay but
sometimes happens if you really want to
play quicker again night be six years
simply I'm simply oblivious to the IDM
and here we just have this position
which is yeah also winning now but yeah
he had just everything falls apart he
should definitely I think avoid to trade
on b3 after all this is a really a key
moment here he should instead I guess go
to a six wait
here ya go here and this is probably
okay I the Queen yes it's a little bit
unusual but ok there's no bishop here on
this diagonal so there are no tactics
coming and it's not so badly placed here
i might go here or night to be 62 h XC 4
that's quite ok for black ok thanks for
watching